[Applause]
watching as tunisia's president does
everything in his power to gain more
power
political rivals are uniting in
opposition
four parties issued a joint statement
saying saeed has lost his legitimacy
while the largest party in parliament
anada accuses saeed of trampling the
constitution born out of tunisia's 2011
uprising
at the store the tunisian people are
against violence we hope that the nada
the other parties in the civil society
will fight to recover their constitution
and their democracy
on wednesday
declared that he will rule by decree and
no longer abide by parts of the
constitution he says he's preparing to
change the political system after
sacking the prime minister freezing
parliament and assuming executive
authority in july
denying charges of a coup paise insists
his aim is to establish a true democracy
where the people are sovereign
he now has the legislative and executive
powers in his hands which means that
tunisia is now entering a new
transitional phase which can be called
the temporary phase the country will
suffer just like it has over the past
two years
[Music]
many tunisians have backed saheed and
believe he's trying to oust a political
elite viewed as corrupt and incapable
must open his door and hear the people
he must listen to the qualified people
we do not want him to listen to the
politicians he must listen to the top
talents that exist in the country so
that they can draw an economic roadmap
but even one time political allies are
now turning against the president
we think that the president has now
decided to deviate from the
constitutional legitimacy and the
legitimacy of people's will
in 2011 tunisia was the first country to
rid itself of autocratic rule in what
would become the arab spring i would
expect that in one or two months
because of social economic reasons we
may see
the beginning of uh
of opposition in the street that would
actually join
the anger of the political elite that is
happening right now
protests are already planned for sunday
in the same square where more than two
decades ago the people rose up against
then president ben ali
leah harding al jazeera